some basic beginner details on this okay
so he has to see he has to see at a
range where he would actually do it
so uh where he'd actually do damage okay
so
kissing the surface of me is going to
change the my of the form that will
change the logic of the form it will
eventually be illogical
okay but i can't start here either so
that he gets ski
because that's the wrong my for starting
too
so you have to figure out where you need
to be uh
and how he needs to ski so he's gonna do
his thing
and he has to get through the target
okay
sometimes your beginner partner is way
out there
and they ski and they're nowhere near
doing it okay or sometimes they start
close
because their footwork sucks and you
that would be the wrong my two
okay so you just uh to learn it correct
yourselves accordingly
okay um next for mine
we're going to do this from ushito
tencon
we're not going to do it from
the yokomed footwork because he's doing
a one to two step footwork
and i don't have the speed to go one
two three okay so it's
shiro tank on uh
he goes when i give the opening
so right now there is no opening so when
i give the opening
he goes okay
and i will so
i'm going to shift my weight onto the
back foot and prep
for the yoshido tank and then move my
body
out of the way so in yoshido tank
on for the same reason i'm going to go
one two three
push the tank on i don't go one two
one step only okay nice and slow
so one bach
that's all i get and i am clearing the
line
okay second point
this is going to already be in prep for
my other hand to go on
don't transfer hands in the middle
of moving it like this you won't have
the power hand
so it's not needed for the block here
then the power head can go on and you
get a full stroke
what would be different is your hair
you're turning it
you'll catch it somewhere around here
that's not much of a power hand stroke
so set it up once
hit when you hit you're going to turn
your hands
this is in your comment here
one here so it's basically
showman but you turn your hands
that's how you get the kesa
one two
okay as a target
okay so when i do tessa
i'm not turning it with my right hand
that's
not very powerful so a lot of people go
like this they go like this and this is
cosmetic
my left hand is going to reach up
and do the strike so don't turn it
cosmetic left hand is going to reach
and the left hand does the strike left
hand
reaches the strike
not my right hand
then it's with my body so i don't go
into my step
and then swing my body is moving
no strength just movement
okay let's try it um
so when he goes don't move his weapon
you're at this angle here i'm underneath
him underneath
him is the cross don't move his weapon
so i make contact but i'm going to
go as angled underneath as i can or as i
have to
better said as opposed to moving
my foot straight foot on my right is
pointed at him
keep your left foot no more open than
the 90.
or slightly closed if you go open to the
weight goes to the outside of your heels
you'll see
i'm falling backwards
also don't twist up
your right foot and knee is going
against the swing
this is not anatomically fit or correct
here okay
okay so i
he see i'm going to move off the circle
this way so i'm back on the spine
alignment
my weapon's gonna pass the middle line
here
and don't break it keep the middle line
up
uh you'll clear the weapon and then your
ski
right here and same thing is past
him to penetrate
[Music]
okay let's go again tomorrow you have to
start with the my okay
so uh oh this is wrong this is wrong
okay um the my
has to have a reasoning that he has to
use his weapon
and that he doesn't try to close the gap
and grapple or disarm
you have to be in that sweet spot okay
so if if if i'm starting this close hole
i check i'll check the weapon and i can
use my empty hands i don't have to worry
about
the okay um
so i gotta start in that sweet spot as
we go
and uh if i move up here like this
i'm in that same thing he's not gonna
sit there and defend he's gonna rush
and uh we're gonna grapple over the
weapons okay
so when when i move up this circle
it's not he's can't get there on time
you see
it's too far for him to go let me grab
and close okay and there's a threat
in there
at the same time i can't be too far i
can't go back out
there's nothing there he doesn't have to
defend himself it's easier for him to
just back
out a distance okay
so let's look at the second one i go
back
out it's very hard to i'll move to you
okay
go back where you were it's very very
hard
to commit forward and go back
out and you have to learn to commit
forward okay secondly
aikido's overall
pattern is spiral and this is not a
spiral
so the fight overall is going to rotate
so as i go in the fight is rotating
we're starting to spin okay
so i want that overall spin and i don't
want to have to stop by motion or
half-past my penetration
so when i go in i can move here
and it'll be very hard athletically to
fully commit
and then come back up
i also don't want to have a yin opening
so i'm not going
yet even if i could do it i don't want
to do it i don't want to lose the
initiative
which is why you use the spiraling
pattern okay
so as i go i'm going this way
okay this way then i'm in range
for everything i need to do
now too close
too close happens when you're moving
across the radius
instead of around the radius so instead
of moving
around the technique you cut through the
middle
you see that you're going to get too
close and then he's going to grapple
so here
move up the radius of the radius
don't cut across the radius
okay now let's try to get orientation
uh so when i go i don't wanna
this isn't where the fight is the
fight's over here
so foot's pointing at him okay and
you're going to do the technique
embryonically
so this is not my cancer it's just
drilling
uh don't move his weapon
you go around his weapon straight down
boom
so no here
then don't move his weapon straight down
ski right here
oriented this way your sunshine
everything is this way
and your feet are under your hips
just like in on me okay
if you don't have that and you go like
this
you see it's usually because you cut
across the radius
you violated the mind you'd be in
grappling or
sidekick i would
use the front foot but okay all right so
uh boom feet
under you there's also something else to
consider
the deeper your stance is here not only
are you closer now to
his body weapons but your ski
penetration is decreased
okay because you're already
shot your thrust and you want your foot
back here
and then you can move much further
so boom here don't move his weapon
go around his weapon here oriented
forward
okay let's go okay because
in essence i double penetrated okay so
i'm going and i came forward again
right and then forward again the fight
got close
you see and that that's what you want is
that
not only do i have a rotating geometry
but i have a pulsing geometry
okay uh so the fight's going to get in
and then it's going to go out so it
follows the natural
force of the natural
nature's way okay so he goes he goes
nope he goes
[Music]
he's gonna come in oh and you see how
close we are so you you're still not
watch don't move your feet finish your
ski you see
uh this he should have really finished
me so i'll show you what i mean
okay so uh i go
i'm moving come back dude you see how i
test your foot
put it back under my foot okay you see
where i am
this this is where i want to be
so if you just look at my goal as an
offensive
onslaught okay just watch me
don't ditch it this time so it's an
offensive onslaught
is what i'm doing
forward i'll show you the difference
okay so let's go
you do the offensive onslaught forward
forward forward there you go okay try it
again
don't follow my weapon just fight me
that's it you don't need to hop
there you go it's still too lateral
keep your offensive um
there you go that's it again
nope you change the technique
there it is okay now go slower okay
you're still freaking out
and that's where i go here okay
so go we just rewind the film okay
i'm going to do another ishiro tencon
he's going to come in
and i'm going to go around it here
[Music]
okay threatened
boom and then because he was coming in
with his energy
[Music]
okay uh we'll switch roles
i'll show you what you're doing you're
stopping
okay so i go
boom hi come on dude
but what was my goal
just you do the foot maneuvers can you
hear without the weapons
so i'm coming in coming in
okay
coming in and just coming in
with the weapon coming in
and just coming in okay
slow down and relax i'm not even doing
the weather
[Music]
oh come on you he has to catch me hi
you're catching me coming in you're not
catching me going out
you're not catching me stopping so when
i do my ride
i can't do this makes no [\h__\h] sense
okay and i
is guys coming in guys coming in
come in guys coming in guys coming in
guys coming in and he runs into my
weapon
so watch as i do the seat
i don't stop my on spot
that's it okay so make sure you're not
doing your ski
in that zigzag
and hanai is a passive technique so
it's not that i come in he hits me it's
a stockpin
do you get it stop hit move your weapon
out of the way
and he keeps walking at me boom that's
tada
okay stay there this is a front kick
it's a stop hit okay he's coming in
that's what harass doing he's coming in
i hit him he runs into my weather
okay so i have to do what is the okay
come in okay and i can't be freaking out
so i'll be there again
don't freak out
and you don't freak out
when you freak out you buy away somebody
go back to these towers
okay it doesn't make any sense marshall
and slow down cause you're still
freaking out i'm not moving
get off the wall
two died behind that smooth so
[Music]
this way get the s out of there
the guy is trying to jab my face who
moved it out of the way
so
[Music]
this way
you got something
one step
[Music]
get out of the way i don't want you to
do a form yet
okay go all right so watch watch my roll
again
everything is in motion
[Music]
that's what i'm doing okay
so let's look at what i do with the
weapon now
with my weapons
[Music]
top i go on the outside of this rewind
though
so there's the cross he's going around
i'm sorry
okay he's going around and i come around
go back so energy
okay he's going around sorry
[Music]
he goes around and there it is right
there okay
uh which you'll do naturally if you
don't want to get hit
you'll keep contact with his weapon okay
there we go
well what i don't want to do is this
just keep the contact they call me
home
go there it is
[Music]
so
so again just the footwork i'm coming
in deviate home
deviate
because i had forward progress
progress over progress forward progress
not in out
in out now
so progress
progress progress boom hit
[Music]
boom
okay let's try okay so the feet
the feet follow the same rules every
time so
my foot front foot is always aiming at
his spine
and my rear foot can't break that 90
rule
and i never stand like this okay
so pointed at him 90 rule
to that line of it's half it doesn't
matter what we're doing so we'll go
i'm doing the first part same thing
go back please 90
point at him pointed at him front foot
90 he moves up
pointed at me and he can't turn that
foot past the 90. do it please
no okay he goes whoa
right uh he goes in and he has
90 and then he fought this pointed at me
and then same thing on the back foot so
when i do
hadai pointed at him
and i had to say 90 rule so no
no no 90 room
okay he goes on boom
pop this foot point at my spine my spine
and then he has a lift up your back
pokemon he has that same 90 rule there
and i am still in that 90 rule here
okay that footwork never changes
okay we uh we go up
you see i'm playing this yielding role
here the yielding rule
yielding wool okay and now
when he went in this kind of hidden role
as he's going around the back of me
this
[Music]
so whoa
draw
uh
[Music]
hmm
open
[Music]
penetrating boom come on
boom it goes around me
that's the banu again
switch
stay with me
don't go in and out
oh
[Music]
okay
but i i'm too much you touch sticks
and you lose the uh the mock okay
you lose you start fighting the arrow
and you stop fighting the archer okay so
it's just my body
move adjust move
move move that's it
you're ahead of me because i'm driving
right at the end
stay with me i'm driving i'm driving
i'm driving stay with me
i push i push
i turn come on
shoulder there you go
can you do it
okay a push
[Music]
oh
boom
so now how do you do the weapon okay the
class is on the mod
but we'll go over the oil
pull it out
[Music]
okay so to work on the my it's good to
go slow
uh but my is space and time not just
space
okay um
and if you look for angles
of deflection
you're going to end up with the wrong
mind so we already mentioned this one
time
okay it would be on
machiatosh okay so i see so i'm coming
in
and i'm not going block that's not the
technique
okay so i don't block his joe so i don't
have
energy going that way and
i don't have energy going that way i
don't deflect his joke
okay when you're going slow you can do
machitos embryonic embryonically but you
have to not
adopt an angle of deflection okay
so as i said when i come in we're this
is now
just the starting place of this
technique and i know it
looks like i'm doing that but i don't
want to
stop his joke so he stops i stop
and come straight down so uh just a
little quicker
that's okay this is not my kids
that's embryonic training okay so
if it's going straight down
inside his curve and that's exactly what
you're doing on the last technique too
okay so he skis and i'm coming around
oh
that's not where i hit this technique so
hiss go rewind the film
rewind the film look forward to dude
okay
so remember my body is moving with his
body he's trying to pass me
i'll pass with him
boom you see rewind
so my weapon is boom
i hit him in the stop hit in the same
stop hit fashion
so i don't i don't stop him this way
rewind it this boom right here never
gets out
okay never gets out
so it comes straight down my body
[Music]
okay can you do it
that's it
try to move my body
and orient on me it's a little bit to
your left
[Music]
that's it
on his leg the theme of the technique is
the ushiro tank
on this quesadilla you don't change
hands though
it's too fast
same thing so
no no
no here
here
[Music]
okay hi yeah i
i hate to throw sensei around but
you're in a lineage and you're [\h__\h]
up a hallmark of his lineage
okay so i'll show you what i mean
let's put it down uh he's gonna
he's gonna do yokoman okay
so he does yoko man it's very common in
aikido
to go tv on
[Music]
and the reason why is you're moving into
the cross lateral armor
okay that's why they do do kim the
attempt
say you're like i occupied his arm
you see but you're still
going into his energy you see
uh so he's coming in
uh i'm doing your program you're going
to do it
he doesn't even know it okay which is
good if you guys
but i'm there you see
i can get it back to him i don't have to
block his strike i can do a stop hit
on his strike do you understand he
doesn't get to determine what how i
psychologically respond to him
okay so um
sensei's saying was not here obviously
that's the clash
but but the tencon
so not here and then turn
but haven't fallen into the hole back
here
then you have
hence we do the form
i don't go one two do you see
i don't go one two
and it goes all the way to the end so
he's coming around
right i'm going around
boom he comes down
i'm not gonna go one you see
two i'm not going to go into okay his
weapon is
on my spine down i absorb when you kill
me
it's coming up this way
this way don't move his weapon off to
the side
you're underneath it the cross is
underneath it
so work the cross and shift on this foot
and you're on the other side of the
weapon
without needing that immediately and you
have it right
usually you do one
two because you don't have weight
shifting
so you need to move your center of
gravity
by double pivoting one two
or usually you're afraid so on this last
one
he comes in and go down
and this is like whoa and you're trying
to get out of the way you need to bait
the guy
boom i have contact right there he can't
hit me
he can't hit me and my mushino tencon is
not a retreating
it's a revectory so is where i hit that
thing i'm attacking i'm tactically
repositioning i'm not retreating okay
let's try it again